هادئه تبدو حدود بيلاروسيا مع اوكرانيا
للوهله الاولى
خلف تلك المدارس تحشد اوكرانيا قواتها
وهنا على الضفه البيلاروسيه يواصل حرس
الحدود تدعيم الشريط الحدودي مع الجاره
اللدوده
انشات هندسيه مجهزه باحدث اجهزه المراقبه
ودوريات تكادلات تتوقف على مدار الساعه
فالوضع رغم الهدوء الخادع يبقى متوترا
والاستفزازات من قبل اوكرانيا كما يصفها
الجانب البيلاروسي زادت وتيرتها مؤخرا
صعب استبعاد حوادث حدوديه لان المجموعات
الاوكرانيه المسلحه اما مكونه من متطوعين
او من وحدات الدفاع الاقليميه وهي غير
مختصه بحمايه الحدود ولا يفهمون ان اي
استفزاز يمكن ان يتطور الى مواجهات حدوديه
حقيقيه باستخدام السلاح
لا تلاحظ العين حشودا عسكريه روسيه او
بيلاروسيه قرب الحدود
ربما تكون في عمق تلك الغابات
فتحركات بيلاروسيا وروسيا العسكريه اثارت
مؤخرا حواجز كثيره على الضفه الاخرى من
الحدود
العسكريه
فكر في الاعتداء على بيلاروسيا انطلاقا من
اراضي اوكرانيا او حلفائها الغربيين وانها
ليست لغز احد
تزايدت مؤخرا للتهامات الاوكرانيه
والغربيه لمينسك بعزمها مشاركه حليفتها
موسكو في حملتها الاوكرانيه والسماح لها
باستخدام اراضي بيلاروسيا منطلقا لاجتياح
عسكري جديد لاوكرانيا كما حدث في بدايه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه قبل عام
رئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكيشنكا اوضح
خلال لقائه بصحفيين اجانب في اي حاله يمكن
لبلاده ان تكون شريكا في المعركه
الاوكرانيه
انا مستعد للقتال مع الروس من اراضي
بيلاروسيا في حاله واحده فقط ان جاء ولو
جندي واحد الى اراد بيلاروسيا لقتل شعبي
من تجراتم على الاعتداء على ارضنا فسيكون
الرد مرعبا
يقول المثل الشعبي السلافي الجار لا يختار
مثلا ينطبق على بيلاروسيا التي تحشرها
الجغرافيا بين روسيا والغرب
الجزيره بيلاروسيا